foreign
thanks Alex thanks for organizing this
and
it's been a great Workshop
I'm going to talk about a project with
um Eunice abash and before getting into
the project I want to spend some time on
some empirical background motivating
what we're doing in this model and the
basic motivation for this are two sets
of facts one is that there's a lot of
homophilia networks that we see so
networks tend to be segregated on all
kinds of Dimensions this is just a
typical picture this is one from a study
of the ad Health Data set where these
are students and these are friendships
and they're color coded by um race and
we see a pretty strong separation
between the friendships between blacks
and whites in this High School I think
there's only
you know it's less than five friendships
across those boundaries
um that that is fairly typical here's
another picture that's from a study
um of Indian Villages
uh we did about it almost a decade ago
now and
um these are households now and this is
a network of sharing kerosene and rice
and this is color coded by cast and the
red nodes are the relatively
disadvantaged schedule cast and
scheduled tribes the grayish nodes are
General and otherwise backward casts
which are the relatively advantaged
casts and again you know here there's
about a 15 times higher chance that two
households are interacting if they're
within the same cast designation than a
cross and you know you can also see
[Music]
um
you can see for instance that there's a
big cut between a scheduled casts and
scheduled tribes they don't intersect
much
um so there's a lot of patterns here
there's a big literature on community
detection we actually have one of the
world's experts here on that
um so you can begin to see that these
Network segments along different lines
and another piece of background that I
want to keep have you keep in mind is a
very different relationship this is an
economic relationship between inequality
and immobility and this is what's known
as the Gatsby curve and it was made
famous by Alan Krueger in a 2012 speech
to Obama
um and it's a was originally pointed out
by
um miles korak and what it is is it's a
relationship between inequality
um which is on the y-axis here in
immobility which is on the x-axis so
inequality is measured as a genie index
which you can think of as randomly
picked two people from the population
ask how much more income does the Richer
person have compared to the poorest
person if that is zero then you've got a
fully equal Society if that is one then
you've got sort of full inequality and
so Genie coefficients are measures of
that that's one way you can think of a
genie coefficient and here you can begin
to see that you know the numbers tend to
be between about a quarter and up to
like somewhere in a 55 percent range and
the x-axis here is immobility and that's
asking take a look at a kid look at
their parents income and then look at
their income when they grow up and see
how correlated those things are so if
they're strongly correlated then
basically the kid has no chance to
escape whatever the parents fate was
that's going to be the kid's fate so a
correlation of one is really bad a
correlation of zero means that the kid
can end up anywhere in the income
distribution regardless of what their
parents starting conditions were and so
here what you're seeing is that there's
a strong relationship between these two
societies that are very unequal also
tend to have a lot of immobility and
we're going to look at that also in U.S
data on a microcosm and we'll see that
this is a pretty strong relationship
there as well and we can the idea is
going to be that homophily is going to
give us an idea of why we see this kind
of relationship
okay so that's one of the other facts I
want you to have in mind
okay so there's several reasons that we
could believe that homophili would have
this kind of impact on uh this um kind
of interaction
um one is that jobs tend to flow through
networks this is the work I've done with
Nicole lamolica and and Lucas bolt if
you have a network of connections where
people are hearing about job information
from their friends then if you have one
generation where you've got a lot of
inequality and employment then the
people who have employed communities are
going to tend to have better chances of
getting better jobs and so that
transmits itself not only within a
generation but across Generations so you
get an inequality within web generation
and inequality across the other is that
you could have pure influence stories
where you know people decide whether or
not to drop out of high school or what
they're going to do based on what their
peers are doing and if you have a lot of
homophily then you're going to tend to
have cool groups of people following the
same Norm terms and dropping in or out
in in unison
um and that you know this also gets to
work with aspirations identity
um pressures there's a whole series of
different uh forces that are going to
push in that direction and what I'm
going to spend time on today is is
information and learning and the reason
that I'm going to do that is it's going
to have actually slightly different
implications than the other two and I'll
try and explain how it's different from
those and it's going to tie to Bandit
problems which we've seen a bunch of and
we'll try and tie in what the ideas are
there yeah because one thing that you
don't have estimates which I wonder
where it would fit in your stream or
bricks which is
Would Imagine a society where I for
example say okay to
get into Harvard you have to speak Latin
and you only speak Latin if you have
which parents who teach your letter so I
artificially introduce into my higher
education system
which I know only to people who look
like me will have so
it's well known for example is Advanced
set for a while that put in sort of
language exams which we already have for
the people who came from Africa to
France so it was very clear that at
least up to sometimes the French system
was really set up
to only admit the French French and not
the pianos yes yeah so um right right so
it doesn't fall so here um the three
forces here I'm thinking of our social
network forces and I actually have a
paper that talks about various
influences on inequality and mobility
and there's Financial Capital wealth
reasons you know just wealthier parents
can invest more in my education there's
Prejudice and racist reasons that these
and these are there's a whole series of
sociological theories about racism and
how different groups
um do what you're describing
um there's references to that and then
this I think of as a separate thing
which is just the social network
structure itself without deliberate
actions of some group can have these
kinds of effects and trying to
understand those I think many of these
different forces are at work and this is
just an exposition of some of them yeah
so so those were probably more into fall
into strategic actions on networks to
actually yeah I mean I guess you know a
lot of that's
um right I mean you have to tell a story
for why there's this kind of prejudice
and uh and then you know the actions
that people are gonna have and what
their payoffs are from keeping things
exclusive and so forth
um which would be a different set of
stories then this is going to be more of
a story of things that go on in the
network
um once the Network's there
okay so I'm gonna give you some
empirical backgrounds I'll talk a little
bit more about homophily
um in two different sets of facts about
homophily and then a quick model of
learning and how it produces
um these facts
so monthly Mobility I'm going to talk a
little bit about this recent study with
Raj Shetty um Teresa Cooper you know how
to struggle and like a team of people
um Mike Bailey from Facebook and then a
lot of uh Ras and basically we were just
looking at at Mobility patterns in the
Facebook data and
um you know we drew this this spring the
last was the last draw of the data 72
million individuals we looked at 25 to
44 year olds because that's sort of a
sweet spot of both being able to cover a
lot of the US but also being able to see
information about their high schools
their parents and their outcomes so it
gives us sort of the right picture for
looking at mobility issues uh I won't go
through all the I'm happy to answer
questions but not going to go through
all the different demographics that are
there but the idea of this study was
originally to sort of look at different
forms of social capital and how those
could be measured via Network and other
demographic data and then to see um
which ones of these were highly
correlated with economic mobility and so
there's you know you could break these
into different categories and let's
break them into three different
categories
um so you know the first is what putting
them for refers to is bridging Capital
so the idea is this is sort of access to
information
um and this is really going to be sort
of inverse homophily so how well
integrated is the network in terms of
having people be able to reach other
individuals and get information in their
Network
um so that will think of as some
bridging cohesiveness and this will be
related to
um the the work that Dean Eccles talked
about with long ties and um you know and
others have been working on uh then
there's cohesiveness so we could think
of this as bonding capital and this goes
back to stories by Coleman and and
actually symbol and you know a long
standing tradition in sociology about
having close-knit groups allows a
community to function better so that if
everybody knows each other then they can
enforce Norms I know if somebody cheated
that spreads quickly we can ostracize
the person so tightly knit societies
should be stronger in some ways so
clustering coefficients
um there'll be different measures we can
look at for this and then lastly Civic
engagement and this is um you know trust
culture Norms these other kinds of
things and there's a series of of
measurements of this that have come out
since um putnam's book which look at
various measures of this and try to
correlate that as well okay so those are
the kinds of the background and the key
thing of homophily that we're going to
look at is what we termed economic
connectedness and what we'll do is from
the Facebook data we can estimate
um people's incomes so we build a
machine learning model to estimate
incomes and then we'll break people uh
in we'll do a median break and we'll
call people either poor or Rich and then
we'll ask what's the fraction of a poor
person's friends that are rich so if
there was no homophily that should be 50
if there's full homophily it should be
zero percent
okay and we'll normalize that by a half
so it goes from zero to one so one means
full homophily there's no interaction
between rich and poor
um uh zero means that there's full
interaction
okay and and so
um that's the measure we'll look at and
then what we did is
we're friends with above what's the tool
so this is the fraction of my friends
who are above median income and then
we're just going to normalize that by a
half right so if it's one it's in the
case of totally unbiased mixing is one
yeah exactly okay and what was zero zero
be sorry yeah yeah yeah so zero is is
complete uh homophily and and one is is
it's complete mixing yeah yeah
yes so yeah I am near religion and my
friends are like some of them
yeah yeah so um so this this kind of
broad median cut is going to be pretty
coarse and then it's going to make a big
difference like what these kinds of
connections are uh originally we did the
paper with quintiles so we broke it into
five pieces and then we looked at the
lowest quintiles of the highest
quintiles so that they were separated uh
the results pretty much completely
replicate whether you do that so we have
all that in the appendix you get higher
Acuity with the median split
um so you get better data in smaller
locations
um but it you know there's differences
and actually you know which quintiles
are connecting to which ones or you can
look at those distributions and so forth
so uh you know the most important
connections actually turn out to be
between the poor and not the highest
quintile but the second the highest
quintile
um so above median but not the richest
and and so you can actually you know
unpack this more but I'm just going to
show you the um Porter Rich data
okay so then what we did is just look
this is result from multi multivariate
regression on uh of a a measure of
upward mobility and so this is um
looking at the stuff that Raj Chetty had
done on upward Mobility so you look at
somebody born into the 25th percentile
of income so their their parents income
is 25th percentile so they're sort of
halfway through this below median part
and then you ask
um where do they end up and so you can
look at that by different areas and so
um here we're doing county level
regressions so look at each County and
ask how well does the somebody who's
poor in that county grow up in terms of
rich and then we can look at these
different measures of social capital so
this is the economic connectedness you
can do a similar measure for language
connectedness
um age connectedness then you can do
clustering coefficients support ratio is
is something related to these long ties
it's asking how many of your ties have
friends in common
um spectral homophily measure so this is
a looking at the Spectrum of the if the
first eigenvalue of a stochastic sized
version of The Matrix and then these are
different trust and Civic engagement
um measures so two questions
[Music]
yeah so the the um the mobility numbers
here are the county how well the county
does on the mobility so what we it's
looking at the 35 year old income
um so you look at a kid so look at them
uh when they what their parents income
was so the the way that the Cherry work
they look at Census Data they look at
the child they look at the parents
income and then they look at the uh so
they get a rank of that when the child
is in their teen years and then they
look at the 35 year old income of the of
the parent or sorry of the child when
they grow up so the users are either the
range of the age of themselves of 25
. yeah yeah so we're not measuring the
specific income just of our users we're
using the income of the historical
um data of how well that County fares in
terms of poor kids growing up to be rich
so it's actually not the the specific
outcomes of those
um we also have data on that but we
that's not this graph
it's like just the way you describe
support ratio made it sound like the
stuff Dean showed us in the virtual
session Wednesday morning where he was
saying like
she's kind of like support ratio is
actually very correlated with yeah and
this is the multiple regression so when
you run it with economic connectiveness
that the correlation
um is heavily mitigated
so I don't have the raw correlations in
this graph but it has a strong it also
there's some interesting interactions
there as well
um I I'm happy to talk more about what I
think is going on there after
[Music]
okay so uh so then
um
okay okay sorry uh so first of all I
want to show you the Gatsby curve again
so Gatsby curve what we can do here is
now let's look at the counties let's
look at their upward Mobility so this is
mean income rank at age 35 for children
with parents at the 25th right so this
is the measure and now we're gonna we're
gonna look at what the genie coefficient
is in a given County and then here you
see the strong negative relationship so
higher income
inequality lower upward Mobility right
so this is that Gatsby curve there's a
relationship and now it's a negative
relationship because we're looking at
Mobility rather than immobility okay so
it's a strong positive relationship or
sorry negative relationship in this the
way it's put here and then
um for some reason that came there's
once you put in economic connectedness
you basically mitigate this relationship
so economic connectedness
um now explains what's going on in terms
of you know statistical prediction and
income inequality is no longer part of
the story so the idea here is
um if you get economic connectedness
then you're getting inequality uh low
inequality and high Mobility if you've
got no economic connectedness you're
getting high inequality and higher
mobility and so the economic
connectedness here is is um you know
mitigating and explaining what's going
on between these two relationships
um
Alex and Alex
yeah so these are um National ranks but
you can also do it locally ranked uh you
get pretty much the same relationships
when you do local rankings
it's gonna be highly correlated and
that's that's exactly why you're getting
this relationship yeah I don't know the
correlation off the top of my head but
it's it's in the 0.4 to 0.5 range like
if the society is perfectly equal the
economic connectedness would be one
right yeah
okay so so basically the idea is that
we've got a Gatsby curve and then you
you once you look at this cross
connections you can begin to explain
that
um
uh you can also do other kinds of things
like you can look at
um upward Mobility for blacks or whites
uh and you can look at sheer black and
you get the same kind of relationship so
it's it it's also explaining partly
what's going on in different racially
segregated areas once you look at the
economic connectedness then you can
explain what the mobility patterns are
um
yeah and that economic connectedness is
still the same one so it's not so this
is um
I mean could it be like a black person
connected to a white person
yes exactly so one thing that's true
here is so this is an interesting
relationship I I don't have time to talk
about all the details of this but what's
what one thing we're saying here is look
once you control for whether there's
good Connections in the network then
whether or not
um it's segregated you know what what
the racial composition of the area is
doesn't matter in terms of predicting
upper Mobility so black and white
Mobility different areas look similar
once you connect for economic
connectedness however what is true is in
areas where you have more diverse racial
populations you tend to have lower
economic connectedness
so there is a there's that racial
division is highly predictive of
economic collectiveness but once you
look at economic connectiveness that's
what's predicting the mobility yeah and
I that's
very interesting question because
there's Spectrum the fact that mostly
itself wasn't predictive seems to be
picking up that there is some cut a lot
of these places are segregated it's
really the economic segregation which is
you know somehow it matters even if
there's for example racial exactly so a
good conjecture in terms of why spectral
homophily didn't matter is is spectral
homophily is is always pretty high no
matter what area you look at it tends to
be there's some cut in some division
it's religious or other kinds of
Divisions
um but the it's it's the economic
division that seems to be the one that's
predicting stuff
it's a Civic engagement coefficients
negative in here yeah and so one
explanation for some of the Civic
engagement stuff especially on Facebook
is that what's actually happening in
terms of some of these local
um types of Social Capital where people
are heavily engaged is actually because
there's a lack of mobility and there's a
lack of Institutions that are doing well
for people then people tend to have
strong cohesive volunteer groups and so
forth so if you look at it turns out
that in the poorest neighborhoods you
have the most volunteer you know the
highest volunteering rates
um uh poor blacks tend to volunteer at
higher rates than wealthy whites for
instance so there's you know there's a
lot of patterns that are going on and
you can think of that as sort of reverse
causation the lack of Mobility is is
causing a high rate of Civic engagement
that that's a story I don't know if it's
true but it fits the data
so this may be uh
um so do you have a sense of what the
source is of the economic connectedness
so is it coming from a club is it coming
from the job is it coming from a high
school is it so we have a whole second
paper where we break down things by high
schools colleges clubs
um churches neighborhoods you can see
the patterns you can see the by the
sizes of these things I I don't have
time to go through that paper today but
there's a whole paper do we have a
sentence answer to that like what it
matters a lot okay that's not the source
The Source matters and there's different
patterns by by poor and Rich they're
spending different amounts of time in
different places
um different uh sizes of Institutions
matter
um the compositions of those so there's
a lot we know about those things but
that's a whole second paper
do you know what happens if you look at
this hemophilia across race and I have
left foot across uh and come together
what do you mean like is there an
interaction between them yeah or is it
still like
I assume there's some effect if you
request on him after they pass rates but
I was wondering if yeah yeah so that's
um
uh that looks a lot like the previous
one that looks a lot like the
spectrophone okay yeah
okay second thing I want to talk about
is that
um so this is homophily Mobility another
thing I want to mention is that it turns
out that there are different types of
people in terms of their monthly
patterns and uh I I want to show you
what that looks like and then actually
try and give an explanation for that in
terms of the model so um this is it from
a study I did with Stephen Nye Eric
snowberg and yeah I really just posted
about a month so ago this is Caltech
we've been studying this for a long time
but we have some individual homophily
patterns that we've been looking at so
the nice thing about Caltech it's a
small place we paid the students we got
pretty much like 94
um uh participation where you had a lot
of high participation rate how much did
you pay them we paid them about 30 for a
half an hour so it was very lucrative
for undergraduate pay
um and then they did a bunch of you know
they they told us information about
their networks and then we did a bunch
of risk assessments and personality
assessments and other kinds of things as
well so there's a lot of data of there
I'm just going to show you a couple of
facts out of that study but there's a
lot more to say so we're going to follow
the 2013 cohort and and we'll look at
them at different points in time
this is calc the 2013 cohort about 35
percent female 65 male
um you know it's uh 47 Asian a little
less than two percent black this is
these are the uh registrars
um terminology so we didn't you know
come up with these groups so we were
stuck with what the registrar had here
so Caucasian 27 Hispanic a little lesson
10 International 10 and so forth okay
um ethnic homophily so what here is look
at two students and ask what's the
percentage of frequency with which they
are connected to each other and then
we'll do that by whether they're
different ethnicity or same ethnicity
okay so you can see homophily here just
in terms of the relative frequency with
which they're connected
um and same ethnicity as a higher
connection rate you know at least two to
one uh gender homophily similar and
fairly large so you see both types of
homophones
and what yeah
go back one it seems that
this is very homophone it also decreases
a little bit but this gender it seems to
decrease more
um yeah so actually the ratio here is
higher in junior slightly higher in
junior year than
so this is different gender
um the the relative percentage by which
this has gone down is bigger than the
relative percentage that that's gone
down but it's you know almost so it's
fairly stable uh it's a little higher
like sophomore and junior year than it
is freshman year
um
so it's more
it becomes slightly more homophilous
over time
too yeah um this one no it's actually
pretty flat so it's it starts out and
then it's it's almost identicals
maybe it's very excited but how are
these networks solicited like what is
the question that you ask them so these
are um name uh up to 10 of your closest
friends how many people name ten uh it's
not so there's a few that name 10 yeah
it's less than I remember the percent
it's less than 10 censored so then we
also asked for study partners I'm not
going to show you the study partner data
but we also have um study partnership
data which is
separate and they name fewer study
partners than they named friends
that
always like it's
it's
no so this isn't this is just like
what's the what's the problem the chance
or frequency with which two people are
connected so if I just pick two students
out of caltech's class and I say are
these two people connected to each other
um and then how does this depend on
whether that that particular dyad is of
the same or different ethnicity
yeah so here the degrees are are small
but the population of Caltech students
is pretty small so the freshman class in
Caltech is about 200 students a year
um it's actually Ben can tell us a lot
about context dude so it's a pretty
small place that the overall student
body is a little less than a thousand
students
average degree is somewhere in the four
to five room each year yeah
okay so the thing that we're interested
in is monthly types and the idea here is
is our specific people more or less
homophilistic so is is it that everybody
has the same kind of monthly the same
tendency to be connecting to other
people or are some people more
homophilistic and other people less
homophilus
and what we're going to do is we're
going to um
okay so we're going to use three
different models to do this and so what
we're going to do is simulate
um the networks and then we're going to
ask what do we actually observe in the
data okay in a way we're going to
simulate this is the following we're
going to do configuration models so
we're going to use a configuration model
to simulate this then each student has a
number of friends so suppose a given
student has five friends
so the simplest model would be what
we're going to do is just take that
student and then we'll give them five to
five friends at random so we just give
them five friends at random another is
we can use a block model where we say
okay look it looks like females have 60
of their friends uh female and 40 male
so we will give each person that has
five friends we'll give them
um probabilistic draws on each friend
which is a 60 40 draw and then we'll see
what they come up with and then there's
fixed types and so what we're doing is
we're looking across the different
periods and so people have freshman
friends and then they have some
sophomore friends that were not freshman
friends
and so what we can do is draw their
freshman friends and then draw their
sophomore friends that weren't freshman
friends and then look at what's the
difference in those laws and so one
possibility is there's no philosophy and
others they follow a stochastic block
and then the other is it will a given
person has a type
and then that type is replicated and the
way we're going to do that is actually
by just taking their actual friends and
just randomly reassigning them across
the different years
okay
and if there if if there's if they're of
a fixed type we should get the same
distribution uh across
okay and so here's what we actually see
so here are this is
um the so what we're doing is we're
looking at ethnicity here gender here
and we're looking at uh these three
different types of simulations so no
types is the blue stochastic block types
is the yellow and then the fixed types
are the red and then here's the actual
value so what we see is the actual value
is out in the tail of of what you would
get from some kind of stochastic block
or no types so it looks like people are
more homophilus and in fact it looks
they're consistent with a fixed type
meaning that the same person has a
higher low homophily level and at
homophily level is the same in a
freshman year then their new friends
sophomore and junior year are drawn
according to that same model as opposed
to just random draws completely random
according to you know a type for the for
the gender or whatever
okay and the same is true of ethnicity
you're saying gender is a block or
racism exactly and that's going to be
important there
which is more like let's learn the
blocks and then what's 92 learning the
blocks is just saying let's suppose that
this person has a particular
um homophily level and then see whether
if it and the model is what we actually
observe in the data is consistent with
the person having the same homophily
each period and that homophily being
different from other people in the
population
yeah so um the second thing is then is
there homophily over homophilus so are
the people who are highly homophilus
connecting with the other people who are
highly homophilus
and what we can do here is we can do a
commit configuration say this is by
gender
um do the configuration model by gender
so keep everybody's friendships by
gender and actually do that and then we
actually do it also by their dorms
because their dorms actually are sorted
a little bit on on gender so you might
get different sorting just by that they
form more of their their friendships
within dorms
um and then the actual value and again
the actual value suggests a higher
correlation so we're getting a positive
correlation here between the monthly of
different individuals
so different people with different
homophily tend to be connected to each
other a high commodity people tend to be
connected with five homography people of
the same type so high hemophily females
are connected with high hemophily
females low homography females are
connected with
same thing with ethnicity it's even more
extreme
um curious fact and this is one we
couldn't we spent a lot of time trying
to figure out whether it is true whether
there's a bug in the data doesn't appear
to be a bug in the data and then I'm
gonna it actually falls naturally out of
the model when you look at mixed gender
friendships so look at friendships
between males and females and ask how do
their Commodities correlate they tend to
be negatively correlated and much more
negatively correlated than you would get
from from just a random model
so when you look at across gender
friendships they tend to be between a
higher homophily male and a low
homophily female or a high hemophily
female and Aloha female
that's the fact stylized fact and then
why would that be how can it be
um and I'll tell you why that works out
in a minute
so is that clear so those are the fact
again from ethnicity it's it's a
stronger
correlation in this sort of city
okay so that's the empirical background
now a whirlwind tour through a a model
and the model is luckily been very well
motivated previously because
um it's a simple Bandit model and so
the idea of this model and this is the
part with you to shabash
um
this homophily so you're going to learn
more from others with similar investment
costs
and different groups are going to take
different actions so the idea is imagine
that we have two different types we're
going to call them greens and Blues
and there's going to be some action that
you might want to undertake for instance
going to college not going to college
and there's a payoff to going to college
you're unsure of it but you can learn
from your friends okay so you learn
about this from your friends and the
tendency is that maybe Blues are
relatively Advantage they have lower
costs of going to college greens are
going to tend to have higher costs to go
to college that's a relatively
disadvantaged group and now
um you're learning from your group and
then the question is what actually
happens in a model like that when you've
got commodity and this kind of Bandit
learning
okay so this is you know you think of
this as in this active learning that
we've been thinking about like
um Morris talked about today the olive
oil kinds of model so Active Learning
but we're going to add homophily into
this and and see what happens in a model
where there's actually homophily in this
kind of stuff whereas you think of
passive learning as you know
homophili can also matter in that
setting but differently
so the key thing is here is what you're
learning depends on the choices of your
group and if greens aren't investing in
college it's very hard to estimate what
the returns to college are for for
agreeing and then greens are going to
tend to under invest then you're going
to get inequality you're going to get
immobility and so that's going to sort
of tie things together but then we'll
also tend to get these patterns up from
offers that I was talking about
so let's think of two continuing groups
blues and greens there's some action
zero just take a minimum wage job and
don't go to college uh that's known and
then there's a risky and costly action
say going to college and your payoff is
some unknown V
and uh for for the purposes of this talk
for for the first part of this let's
just think of this as zero or one so
either it's not worth it or there's a
positive payoff of one with some
probability p on the one so this is the
risky action you're taking
and then you have some CI that you know
which comes from a distribution on zero
one so you've got some costs and now I
want to take the action if the payoff is
one I don't want to take the action if
it's zero and I have a positive cost
okay so I learned the actions and and
failure of success of my neighbors
um some set of people from the previous
generation
so I'm going to have some degree that
I'm going to see you know some number of
people I see from the previous
generation there's some degree that
green people see some degree of blue
people see and then there's a homophily
what are the fraction of same types of
people that I've heard so are green C
mostly greens are they seeing mostly
blue so a homophily of one here would
mean that greens see only greens up
awfully of one for blues would mean
Blues only see Blues in the previous
generation
so it's
by chance of success dependent on my
type no so here we're going to have a
really simple model that that college is
either good for everybody or bad for
everybody and then it's by cost that
determines whether or not it's it's
worth so some people are higher costs
and low cost but then the state of the
world is just going to be the expression
to turn it on so if I see success
in my friends I don't care if I said
black or white because I just deduce
some probability of success Yeah so
basically in this particular in a simple
version so it's going to depend on where
that V is so you know the
um the general model of this has for the
only branches because that can seem more
likely to people yeah let me just yeah
exactly let me sort of Pop through to uh
so let's think of a simple example and
then I'll come right to that so let's
imagine that the blues either half cost
zero or some cost positive cost CB
um the greens either have cost zero or
some cost CG
uh I don't really learn anything from a
zeros because they're going to take the
X's no matter what so I only learn when
I see one of these high costs people
take the action
and like imagine a world where the
greens tend to have higher costs
so the greens have a cost which is above
the expected value of this thing they're
not going to experiment so this is not a
repeated I don't have any value to
experimenting because I just get to go
to college once so I'm only going to do
it if I have a positive expected value
and so here the greens they're they're
null if they didn't learn anything
they're going to tend not to go and the
blues are going to tend to go so the
blues will try out College the greens
would not try out College okay so that's
the starting that's a simple example and
a lot of the intuition of all the
various cases works from the simple
example
so the costs um so the costs so greens
have either a low so there's some
low-cost reads who are just really
talented and can go to college and it
doesn't cost them anything and they get
it
it could be Financial costs it could be
effort costs it could be whatever cost
you think going to college there's some
there's some something that I have to
put in and there's something I get out
and people know what they're going to
have to put in but they're not sure what
they're getting out of it yeah and so
the uncertainty is whether this is going
to be a valuable thing we've just
simplified things in this great example
to have a you know a value of either one
or zero to make things really
transparent
um the general model has a bunch of
different cost values and values
[Applause]
yeah so um I when I when I get to see a
person I can tell what their type is and
what their cost is oh sorry um no so uh
what you're going to learn here
um you're gonna you're gonna see whether
a person succeeds and you're going to
see what their Crossing is
so you'll know whether they got a
positive payoff or a negative payoff and
what their cost was
so let's just go through a simple
example so imagine for instance that the
blues have about uh
20 of the Blues have a positive cost to
going to college so these are the people
I can learn from the zero across
balloons are going to go to college and
get it you know they're going to get a
good payoff no matter what so it's a
it's this 20 that I learned
they're all going to go to college
and so I learned from them the chance
that if one of my friends is blue then
I'm going to learn from them is 20.
now imagine the greens
fifty percent of the greens have the
high cost
so there's many more degrees that have
high costs but fewer of them are
actually going to college
so here in this case even though there's
50 of the greens are high cost I could
potentially learn from them only 20 of
them are actually going to college and
so there's only a 10 chance that one of
my my green friends actually gives me
any information that I can learn from
so this is the situation where homophily
hurts learning I would learn if I'm
agreeing I would learn more from Blues
than from greens
right so so there's this trade-off of
like how many of them have costs that
are similar to me that I can actually
learn from versus how many of them are
actually taking the action that is going
to inform me and so the greens have
costs that are more often similar to me
but they're taking the action less
frequently
so that's the trade-off so we've got
this there's a benefit
um and a cost from learning from the
same type
foreign
so then you go through and green
learning monthly benefit more likely to
have similar costs so I'm more likely to
have somebody I can really learn from
but
um they're less likely to be taking the
high action and so I learned less
frequently from them
and so then you can go through and just
look at Dynamics
so if I'm learning from the previous
generation like you know last year's
students are less cohort of students
this cohort of students now are learning
so it's going to depend on you know
what's the homophily rate how many of
them are going to college
um what's the probability that they have
the same cost as me same thing for blues
you know you can go through and just do
a calculation of what's the probability
you're going to learn from a given
person
and you can follow this and then just
Trace out what the evolution of the
um of the society looks like and so you
can do a steady state calculation so
depending on the degree in the network
the higher the degree the more people
the more draws I get the higher the
chance I'm going to learn so denser
networks in this world are unambiguously
good
and
um this is just a particular example but
then for a homophily of 0.5 I would have
a certain learning period
and what's going to happen here is with
other homophilies
um
the higher the homophily higher levels
of homophily for very low degrees hurts
it's detrimental to learning why is it
detrimental to learning it's detrimental
to learning because
um as we've got very high levels of
homophily the greens are not learning
much because mostly learning from
Greenies most greens aren't able to
learn because they don't have many
observations so almost no greens go you
don't learn anything from greens you get
a really low steady state on the other
hand once you've got a high enough
degree now the greens have a better
chance of learning
and then homophily is good so homophily
becomes better at higher rates so once
you've got a lot of people going to
college then it makes sense to be
learning from them as mentors rather
than learning from somebody who has a
lower you know a different cost than you
do and so there's this trade-off okay
and I won't go through all the details
but when you have multiple costs and
multiple value levels then basically
what happens is
um cost homophily so what you'd most
like to do is be learning from see
people in the population that have
similar costs to you
so whether those be blue or greens you'd
want to be learning from people with the
same costs so the homophily should be a
long cost level people with the same
cost as me are the people that are going
to end up being the most informative to
me
and then when you do that what tends to
happen is that leads to assorted of
homophily and blue green space
so the the if there's a lot of greens
that have high costs then the greens
with high costs are connecting mostly
with greens and when they're connecting
to Greens they're connecting with other
greens with high costs when they're
taking the blues they're connecting with
relatively rare blues and those Blues
are mostly connecting across that gives
you this negative correlation so you get
exactly the pattern so the idea is when
you're actually looking at homophily and
blue green space when you project the
homophilian cost space into that you get
exactly the patterns we see in the
Caltech data
and it's sort of the optimal thing so
here it says you know that's actually
the best for the best outcome for the
population is to have this kind of
assortativity and costs which actually
leads to the homophily You observe in
the data so that's time up so
um
yeah a lot to digest but it's sort of I
think there's a lot of interesting facts
that we can pull together with a simple
models of homophilian learning this was
just a snapshot to give you a flavor for
that but hopefully it piques your
interests
actually
one question
so maybe more
I I was
um curious about the
first part of the paper it seems to be
like uh links across
economic status helped me with mobility
and at a sort of very intuitive level I
would think that if I'm friends with
what it does say is it it's consistent
with the observation that like if I'm a
low-cost I don't want to be connecting
to the the really wealthy
the best kind of connection is the
people who are
um wealthier than me but not too much
well for you
so they have more information they're
going to be more likely to be taking
these actions but have somewhat more
similar circumstances so there's a
trade-off between
your quintile thing yeah yeah so you see
that in the quintiles and then here what
you see is you have to look at a richer
version of the model where you know
you've got richer kinds of mixing of
types and then the optimal thing is
costs that aren't too different but you
know somewhat
all right
this next video is a great device